♪ ♪ ♪
- Des côteaux verdoyants
des plantations de thé
à perte de vue.
Cela fait bientôt
quatre décennies que Hryry Korir
exploite cette parcelle de terre
à flanc de montag
♪ ♪ ♪
Une culture habituellement
Mais pour ce paysan,
rien ne va plus depuis 10 ans.
Au grand dam de Henry,
un passager clandestin s'est
introduit dans sa plantation :
un insecte ravageur
mange tous les bourgeons
et qui a totalement ruiné
sa production.
1000 kilos de thé par mois;
aujourd'hui, il peine
à en cueillir 22.
Seule solutn n pour lui : tout
arracher pour éventuellement,
ensuite, r
Mais désemparé, Henry
se st t un peu seul
face à cette calamité.
Aucune aide des autorités,
qui craignent, à leur tour,d'êt.
- I'm getting discouraged
has persisted so much.
- Et personne n'es l'abri.
Paul Misik l'a appris
à ses dépens.tététététététététét
comptait beaucoup sur
sa plantation de thé pour
assurer ses vieux jours.
Il doit aujourvovovovovovovovov.
Les insectes dévastateurs
la principale source
d'inquiétude de Pa M Misik.
Mais ce n'est pas la seule;
depuis quelques années,
Une impression confirmée
Une impression confirméepar leo
depuis 60 ans : le Kenya
est en première ligneimimimimim.
Et les deux calamités
sont intimement reliées.
Selon une étude récente
de l'ONG Christian Aid,
les changements climatiques
po
les surfaces propices
à la culture du thé
au Kenya d'ici 2050.
♪ ♪ ♪
La crise est loin
d'être anecdotique.
Le Kenya est le premier
Les précieuses feuilles
constituent sa principee
exportation, sa première
source de devises.
plus d'un demi-million
de petits producururs
agricoles à travers le pays.
Alors, dire qu'on s'inquiète
car l'impact des changements
climatueues se fait déjà sentir.
Nickson Okumu est
en contact direct avec
les 12
de thé qui fournissent
l'usine de Tegat, à Kericho.
Nickson lance donc
un appel urgent pour aider
le
Car sinon, au rythme actuel,
l'avenir s'annonce sombre.
Paul Misik, lui, l'a déjà
Nickson lance donc
un app u urgent pour aider
les fermiers à s'adapter.
Car sinon, au rythme actuel,
l'avenir s'annonce sombre.
Paul Misi l lui, l'a déjà
compris : le thé, seul, ne lui
apportera pas la retraite
alors il songe à diversifier.
en jachère et prévoits'acheter .
Et, comme beaucoup ici,
il se désole de l'injustice l ls
ne produisent que 4 % des gaz
à effet de serre dans le monde,
ils sont les principales
victimes de leur imp